public sénat en partenariat avec l' afp
les échos radio classique présente
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
jean christophe cambadélis est l'invité
de l'épreuve de vérité bonsoir bonsoir
et merci d'être avec nous alors que vous
venez de quitter vos rues de fonctions
de premier secrétaire du parti
socialiste
et vous vous lâchez dans cette chronique
d'une débâcle 2012-2017 trois grandes
questions vous seront opposés au cours
de cette émission sur public sénat avec
les échos avec radio classique et avec
l' agence france-presse
1 avec ces réformes économiques sociales
et budgétaires emmanuel macron n'est-il
pas en train de réussir là où vous avez
échoué
c'est ce que viendra vous demandez tout
à l'heure jean francis pécresse de le
parti socialiste pourra-t-il surmonter
sa débâcle vous le dirai à stéphanie le
rouge alors que nous découvrirons
ensemble tout à l'heure un sondage
exclusif pour l'épreuve de vérité un
sondage opinionway sur l'image et le
potentiel d'avenir du ps 3 pourquoi
hollande a échoué à lui ne le pense pas
mais vous oui et on évoquera avec
michael avait certaines pages
saisissante de votre récit du
quinquennat jean christophe cambadélis
d'abord une toute première question
d'actualité
[Musique]
avec bien sûr la dernière sortie
polémique d'emmanuel macron sur ce
qu'ils foutent le bordel on écoute
certains au lieu de demander des frais
c'est à dire garder mais c'est un indien
voilà pour ces propos qui ont été tenus
en aparté a on le voit après une
manifestation des salariés gms en
corrèze
alors on doit arrêter la langue de bois
dit ce soit l'elysée qu'est ce que vous
en dites vous vous entendez cette
défense la présidence rouge c'est des
propos signifiant mais qui n'ont pas été
signifiée ce n'est pas ce qu'a dit le
président de la république à athènes les
français sont feignants enfin non mais
vous vous voulez venir ce qu'ils ont
pensé qu'ils ont précédé ce qui n'était
pas plus aimable dans un débat
républicain dont je crois que c'est des
propos volet on voit bien tu il parle
mais signalé en un but
oui ces signifiants parce que ce lundi
que ben à l'univers culturel du
président de la république univers
culturel du président de la république
c'est un grand classique de la droite
tout ce qu'il dit en ce moment je n'ai
entendu par la droite à savoir que les
français sont feignants qui sont en fait
il faut réforme qui foutent le bordel
voilà c'est tu sais c'est sa manière
d'appréhender les relations sociales
et là il nomme les choses c'est encore
la défense de l'elysée 1 et 10
effectivement il y à des jobs il faut
les prendre et cesser vérification faite
c'est le cas dans cette fonderies
d'ussel où il se trouve il ya des jobs à
prendre et des formations qui vont avec
il nomme les choses n'en sommes pas les
choses il dit qu une manifestation c'est
le bordel dans une manifestation
c'est des gens qui sont en difficultés
qui peuvent avoir un débouché et qui
peuvent prendre des emplois qui leur
seront nécessaires pour vivre mais il ya
une angoisse
il faut la comprendre il faut la
recevoir on peut pas être dans le
surplomb faire la leçon en disant moi je
sais vous ne savez pas vous êtes des
petites gens moi je suis quelqu'un qui
va vous guider
ça ce n'est pas
juste du point de vue de ce que doit
être un peu alors tous les cas le
président verts publics il assume la
teneur de son propos même s'il regrette
l'emploi d'un mot familier bord des dom
il assume
il assume ses propos mais ça s'appelle
un déplacement ça ce qu'il n'assume pas
bordel donc qu'est ce qu'il fait il
parle plus du bordel c'est à dire d'une
manifestation
mais il déplace le propos sur le fait
qu' il y à bien des emplois et qu'il
pourrait être revu pour veut carrément
déjanté mais c'est pas ça le sujet il
fait comme si on était idiot c'est pas
ça le sujet c'est que il pense que des
gens qui manifestent foutent le bordel
ce ne sont pas ces ponts devraient pas
manifester on devrait dire amen ben je
crois qu'il se trompe
la société française elle est plus
complexe que ça en tous les cas plus
rétives à la parole présidentielle dans
votre livre vous avez des mots très durs
koré emmanuel macron vous le présenter
comme le roi soleil
1 vous dit il un regard bleu dur ça vous
a marqué manifestement et vous dites que
c'est le regard de marc gales faveur
c'est thatcher macron non j'expliquais
une situation est-ce que tu allais le
regard de margaret thatcher et le
déhanché de michael je dis quoi je dis
que c'était c'était très étonnant voilà
un garçon qui est un président pardon
qui aimait à l'époque c'était un garçon
qui était aimable pétillant plein
d'allant tactile amicales sympathiques
intelligent tout ce que vous voulez et
puis d'un seul coup vous voyez ce regard
dur
donc je me suis fait la réflexion où il
mal aujourd'hui à mâcon il est vraiment
à fond dans celui qui était map gentil
et caressant ou dans celui qui est dans
ce regard parfois extrêmement dur ça que
je me suis dit voilà
et aujourd'hui il il est plutôt dans
l'homme qui est dur le bordel que dans
celui qui est bienveillant
suite de l'épreuve de vérité avec et
jean francis pécresse le directeur de la
rédaction de radio classique
[Musique]
bonsoir jean francis michel bonsoir jean
christophe cambadélis alors est ce
qu'avec ses réformes
emmanuel macron n'est pas en train de
réussir là où vous aviez échoué
ben on le saura dans quelque temps pour
l'instant on ne peut pas le dire je
pense pas mais peut-être que je souhaite
pour la france il y aura des réussites
en fin de compte la première des
réformes c'est à dire celle des
ordonnances et celle que moi même
j'avais retoqué à l'époque où on m'a
présenté la première loi travail j'avais
dit que dans ces conditions je ne la
voterai pas et ça tombait bien puisque
les sens sans que les syndicats fo
réformiste n'était pas d'accord non plus
et on avait fait évoluer la loi avec un
dialogue entre manuel valls et les
organisations syndicales ont fait une
deuxième loi bon je crois que dans la
flexsécurité qui le déploie il est
plutôt dans la sécurité que peut-on
d'inflexibilité que dans la sécurité
d'accor dans un sondage est là bas que
nous publions ce soir pourrait de
classiques et les échos près d'un
français sur deux 45% jugent que la
politique économique de ce gouvernement
est équilibré vous ne partagez pas du
tout ce constat va se dire qu'il ya 55
qui ne sera que la filiale à 40% qui la
juge trop à droite mais là c'est plus
important que c'est quand même
considérable équilibre moi je conçois
que une partie de la droite si ce n'est
la totalité de la droite s'y retrouve
ce qui fait quand même près de 20 à 25%
une partie de l'extrême droite s'y
retrouver une partie du centre surtout à
partir de là vous avez le résultat de
votre de votre sondage mai
moi je la trouve pas équilibré donc je
ferai dans la partie minoritaire de
votre sondage
qu'est ce que vous apportez votre
soutien aux syndicats qui vont se réunir
lundi pour envisager une action commune
parmi ces syndicats il y avait faux avec
la cgt avec la cftc et avec la cgc
moi je suis quand on est dans un combat
contre les ordonnances je suis pour
l'unité syndicale est donc tout ce qui
va dans le sens de l'unité syndicale me
semble positif
au fond les syndicats à des degrés
divers ne sont pas contents de ces
ordonnances
ils les ont critiqués ils veulent qu'il
y ait des évolutions voilà donc qui
participent ensemble à son premier venu
vous voyez bien quand même qu'il ya ceux
qui vont manifester il ya ceux qui ne
manifestent pas dans ceux qui ne veulent
pas manifesté il ya la cfdt vous au ps
historiquement et culturellement
vous êtes plutôt proche de la cfdt est
ce que par opportunisme
aujourd'hui vous seriez prêt à dire dont
il faut manifester parce que c'est une
ouate 2 non moi je dis il faut mais
enfin c'est maintenant je dis je n'ai
plus à dire je suis plus premier
secrétaire du parti socialiste va vous
parler aujourd'hui librement avait déjà
dit je disais en son temps il faut
manifester si l unité si c'est
simplement une manifestation dirigée par
une organisation syndicale
ça ne va pas il faut s'opposer mais il
faut aussi proposer aux pas être dans
simplement dans l'opposition pour
l'opposition et je pense que ce que
disait de développer la cfdt était très
juste c'est un rendez vous manqué tiens
il y avait déjà une loi travail ce qu'il
manquait totalement
c'est peut-être d'aller plus loin sur un
certain nombre de sujets dans la place
des organisations syndicales dans la co
gestion de l'entreprise c'est d'aller
plus loin dans un certain nombre
d'autres sujets non c'est à dire la
sécurisation des parcours professionnels
ça c'est des éléments qui le sont
nécessaires parce que si vous gens
peuvent trouver que cet équilibre est
évidemment mais si c'est toujours la
flexibilité et vous n'avez pas
d'éléments de sécurité
on est bancal et les français n'adhèrent
pas est ce que dans ce que vous proposez
il ya un véritable projet de
construction est ce que vous n'êtes pas
dans la déconstruction par exemple sur
le budget 2010 8 les socialistes à
l'assemblée au fond propose de remettre
lisf comme il était avant de remettre
les gens ploie aider comme une vidéo
qu'est ce que vous proposez de nouveaux
est-ce que c'est pas juste de remettre
ce que vous aviez fait l'on va pas faire
du nouveau pour faire du nouveau si on a
pensé qu'on avait fait des chenils et eh
bien on va leur proposer évidemment mais
je n'en mets je partais bien le partage
un élément mais je ne prendrai pas sur
la question du budget parce que là nous
faisons notre travail nous ne sommes pas
simplement opposants mais nous sommes
proposant pas c'est vrai le contre le
budget que propose le parti socialiste
c'est de supprimer toutes les économies
qui ont été annoncées et de remettre
l'impôt sur la fortune
ça vous trouvez que c'est suffisant
pression en bas saint laurent est ce
qu'on est en direction des petites et
moyennes entreprises et on veut c'est
une théorie permettre à ce que la
dépense publique booster la croissance
voilà il ya des gars des désaccords mais
je dirais que oui c'est vrai que le
parti socialiste n'a pas encore un
projet politique global qui permette de
redonner toutes ces revendications
ça c'est à construire questions sur le
sur le processus d'indépendance de la
catalogne est ce que vous êtes un
processus que vous soutenez est ce que
vous considérez que au fond le combat
des indépendantistes catalans c'est le
combat de la gauche
moi je suis toujours favorable
centralisation décentralisation contre
la centralisation
je pense que c'est moderne que cela
correspond à notre époque et je le
développe très jeune les pouvoirs est en
france mais je ne suis pas pour le
démantèlement des pays
pourquoi parce que à la fin la catalogne
va se retrouver tout seul parce que les
décisions se prennent à 28 il est peu
probable que si elle quitté
unilatéralement l'espagne l'espagne soit
favorable à son l'adhésion à la
communauté européenne donc elle est dans
une impasse
mais je trouve que la manière dont ça a
été traitée est un peu violent
donc il faut trouver un équilibre entre
le temps la glace quand vous êtes mans
plutôt du côté du camp de dora roye que
du camp non je suis d'accord j'ai
d'abord avec le psoe qui a fait des
propositions
ouais d'approfondissement de l'autonomie
de la catalogne à la fin l'indépendance
de la catalogne devient l'espèce de
revendications absolue on peut trouver
des approfondissements qui permettent
une autonomie qui permettent l alleud la
culture catalane de 2,2 à s'exprimer
sans pour autant démanteler un et âme
et d'ailleurs quand on je trouvais que
au passage la formule de piqué c'est à
dire le joueur de barcelone qui joue
dans l'équipe d'espagne à savoir qu' ils
veulent être plus autonome sans défaire
l'espagne c'est la raison pour laquelle
il joue au barça et dans l'équipe
d'espagne
c'est un très bon résumé c'est un très
beau compromis de ce qui pourrait être
fait est ce que vous êtes inquiet de
l'impasse là bas est ce que vous êtes
inquiets de ses répercussions
économiques eux notamment pas à cette
étape
pour l'instant ce n'est que politique et
je crois que on se retrouve on
retournera vite à table de location de
je dirais que d'un certain point de vue
tout le monde a fait tapis
il faut que leurs mails un moment donné
le le roi d'espagne
rajoy le président de la catalogne tour
n'a fait tapis bon mais alors après
maintenant comment fait donc on va
commencer je crois peut-être y aura-t-il
des des intermédiaires mais on va
commencer à discuter ça l'europe joue
les médiateurs
il faut que le médiateur soit accepté
par les deux parties mais on peut pas
dire je vais prendre suis là parce qu'il
est avec moi donc il faut essayer de
trouver un chemin pour
à faire descendre cette cette tension on
vous suit entre réaction je voulais vous
interroger sur l'europe puisque on vous
sent évidemment à très attaché à l'union
européenne avec le danger que représente
effectivement cette perspective
d'indépendance de la catalogne
le groupe les a soumis à l'assemblée
nationale a demandé à ce que l'on retire
le drapeau français de l'hémicycle
comment est-ce que vous réagissez mais
j'avais déjà entendu ça dans la bouche
de jean luc mélenchon quand il est entré
pour la première fois depuis cyclone
continue t on est on est obligé de
supporter cela en montrant le drapeau
pour moi l'europe ce n'est pas un pays
ennemi
or c'est ce qu'ils induisent je n'aime
pas beaucoup cette manière de traiter
d'autres pays parce qu'il s'agit
d'autres pays d'autres peuples que l'on
peut défendre qui luttent eux aussi ils
n'ont pas moins droit à participer à
l'europe que nous donc il ya là une
attitude
indépendamment du fait que aujourd'hui
la question européenne est une question
essentielle à l'affirmation de la france
mais là il ya une attitude qui n'est pas
bonne on va dire sur cette question
européenne c'est une sorte de fossé
insurmontable entre les insoumis et vous
c'est une question que qu'exacerbe
exprès jean luc mélenchon pour donner un
contenu à son refus de faire l'union
comme s'il n'y a pas il n'y a pas de
raison de faire l'union avec le fait de
venir avec nous mais il donc il exaspère
de cette question il en fait une pierre
angulaire
d'abord parce qu'il pense qu'il peut
récupérer les voix du front national et
que ça lui permet de légitimer son
combat entre le peuple et les élites
mais le combat entre le peuple et les
élites ce n'est plus la gauche c'est un
nom c'est le populisme il peut être de
gauche mais c'est le populisme est ce
que d'une manière puisque d'une manière
ou d'une autre vous en voulez pas un peu
à françois hollande de ne pas avoir su
pour relancer le projet voilà européen
et réconcilier peut-être la gauche avec
nouvelle vision de l'europe je sais au
fond c'est quand même à vous et c'est
dûment autre journal s'est fait l'écho
du discours de françois hollande en août
de l'année dernière devant les
ambassadeurs qu'un décrété et qu'est ce
qu'il ya comme effet aujourd'hui le
discours de macron aucun nom ne vous dit
pas ça françois hollande a fait un
discours
tchité de bonne facture on retrouve
beaucoup d'idées présente dans le
discours d' emmanuel macron la seule
chose qui est différente c'est qu'il dit
qu'il faut aux références entre macro et
hollande c'est qu'il dit qu'il faut
revenir sur les traités or pour revenir
sur les traités il faut être d'accord
perdante emmanuel macron au contraire
oui mais d'accord bercy parce que sinon
vous êtes bloqués il faut bien revenir
sur les traités sinon vous pouvez pas
avancer c'est du processus extrêmement
longs extrêmement lourds et toutes les
précédentes réformes des européens ce
sont précisément heurté à cette révision
des longues donc ce que nous le voulons
faire avancer l'europe
mais bien sûr mais le volontarisme en
europe le monde ne marche pas
monet disait qu'il faut l'engrenage et
là on ne prend pas à l'engrenage
on met au pied du mur les autres pays
alors vous ne dénonce vous ne supportez
pas la dénonciation des élites par jean
luc mélenchon dans votre livre vous
dites que c'est un technocratisme qui
est au pouvoir c'est pas une façon de
d'une part de naissance et les élites
est autre part est ce que c'est si grave
que ça si les résultats sont là
attendons voir attendons de voir les
résultats
mais non c'est l'idée d'avoir pas de
toutes les élites l'idée d'une certaine
partie de l'élite ayant régulièrement
des manuels macron que en fin de compte
la technique est supérieure à la
politique et que si vous dénoncez pas un
chiffre vous ne pouvez pas plaider une
idée c'est le fait que tout se réduit en
équation mais moi je pense que c'est
aussi de cela que meurt la politique
merci jean francis la suite de l'épreuve
de vérité avec stéphanie le rouge qui
nous rejoint notre consoeur de la fp
l'épreuve de vérité un déclic bonsoir
stéphanie alors avant que vous posez
votre question donc ce sondage exclusif
opinionway pour l'épreuve de vérité que
vous allez découvrir en direct jean
christophe cambadélis et on va
surveiller alors vraiment votre réaction
regarder deux questions étaient posées
d'abord quelle image avez-vous du parti
socialiste est bien
au total 80 % de mauvaises opinions
alors assez mauvaise et très mauvaise 80
% de mauvaises opinions
deuxième question posée par opinionway
dans cinq ans le pouvoir le parti
socialiste sera t'il une force qui
compte est bien là il y à 77 % de non
probablement pas 10 50 % des français
certainement pas pour 27% alors d'abord
sur alors là les i peut-être poser la
question les résultats de ce sondage
sont très dure est-ce que vous pensez
que le parti socialiste va pouvoir
surmonter
d'abord devant permettrait d'observer
que ils sont supérieurs aux 6% que nous
avons fait ça veut dire déjà nous sommes
en train de remonter mais c'est normal
c'est normal c'est normal parce que le
parti socialiste est convalescent et
qu'il ne peut pas aujourd'hui incarner
une alternative pourtant c'est le parti
de l'alternative et je pense que petit à
petit petit à petit pas d'un seul coup
ça serait quand même invraisemblable
tu as après une situation où on n'a pas
vu notre président de la république se
présenter nous avons perdu les élections
présidentielles les élections
législatives où le premier ministre a
quitté le parti socialiste le candidat à
l'élection présidentielle a quitté le
parti socialiste d'un seul coup après
les sénatoriales puisque nous sommes
applique sénat tout le monde dise mais
au fait c'est parti socialiste qui va
revenir
non mais j'observe que petit à petit
l'idée fait son chemin
il ya une direction collégiale à 28 qui
vous remplace
on adorait tendance à dire que sa
direction collégiale n'est pas la
meilleure manière d'incarner le ps et
que ça ne facilite pas la cohérence est
ce que c'est un pis-aller comme le dit
olivier faure non je dirais pas ça je
dirais que c'est un passage obligé
à partir du moment où vous n'avez pas de
personnalité qui a cette étape peut
l'incarner pourquoi voulez vous qu'on se
jette les uns contre les autres pour
savoir qui à 20% contre les autres va
être le représentant
non mais là aussi trouvé vous suit les
uns contre les autres au sein d'une même
direction collégiale puisque toutes les
sensibilités sont présentés c'est pas le
cas si on a fait en sorte que tout est
positionné les ans alors de se
représenter sans croyez - d'un moment
cela représente un travail considérable
mais je pense que nous avons été
condamnés à ça à force de s'opposer les
uns aux autres les français nous ont
condamné à travailler
est ce qu'on constate c'est qu'il est
très difficile de trouver des milieux
commune par exemple marie pierre de la
gontrie qui est une nouvelle sénatrice a
regretté qu' il n'y ait pas d'accord sur
le projet de loi antiterroriste voilà
constatant que le seul le groupe au
sénat et à l'assemblée n'avait pas la
même position qu est-ce que vous n'êtes
pas condamné à être constamment dans ses
contradictions il y à des contradictions
parce que la bonne distance entre
l'opposition au pouvoir de gauche et
réaliste n'est pas facile à faire
il y a le fait que l'on doit pas
s'opposer surtout qu'en soit possible de
dire amen à tout moi je partageais la
position de marie pierre de la gontrie
je pense que dire qu' il fallait
intégrer les éléments du texte de
monsieur collomb dans
notre droit public c'était quelque part
dire que ce que nous avions fait n'était
pas juste mais comment est-ce que vous
pouvez compter sur des personnalités que
vous définissez dans votre livre
alors là avec des mots extrêmement durs
sous les rappelle jean-christophe
cambadélis vous parlez du cynisme de
l'affaissement morale du culte
narcissique des choix de carrière que
font les uns raison de vous parler de
vos camarades
alors c'est sûr que vous comptez
aujourd'hui bien sûr parce qu'ils vont
se sont rendus compte ou cela menait et
je pense qu'ils vont faire l'effort de
surmonter cette situation de cette
attitude
cette manière d'être qui font des mots
aussi rude à votre encontre
évidemment vous l'avons avait un bon
bilan mais en off alors c'est parce ccc
c'est un anonyme mais moi je dis
publiquement les choses et j'assume
vous avez dans votre livre vous
expliquez que vous avez toujours tout
fait pour que le ps ne se déchirent pas
qu'il n'ya pas de purge pour garder tout
le monde dans le même bateau c'était un
de vos principaux combats là on voit que
la fédération du
de seine saint denis du 93 a demandé à
mathieu hanotin proche d'am ans de
renoncer à la présidence du groupe ps au
conseil départemental
est ce que ce genre d'attitude
c'est ça vous semble une bonne chose en
ce moment j'écoute et s'il pense que
mathieu hanotin ne peut pas les
représenter c'est un débat démocratique
moi je ne devrais m'interdire et là
dedans on veut pas interférer là dedans
il ya des débats tout de tout temps un
moment donné il ya une élection il y en
a un qui est élu yacht il l'est pas
aujourd'hui mathieu hanotin est en
minorité
demain il sera peut-être majoritaire le
progressisme et que doit aujourd'hui
incarnée selon vous le parti socialiste
face à celui d' emmanuel macron d'abord
c'est il ya d'abord une méthode je suis
je pense que c'est une erreur
l'hypercentralisation actuels du pouvoir
je crois que c'est une fausse analyse du
blocage français il faut une très grande
décentralisation une très grande
déconcentration une capacité à dialoguer
pourquoi parce que général de gaulle
disait la vème république
c'est des institutions pour les français
du moment dans la france du moment les
français du moment et la france du
moment de l'est pas celle de 1947 c'est
le discours de bayeux et pas celle de
1962 c'est une france fragmenté c'est
des français hyper politisée au courant
de tout et qui veulent des six des et
non pas qu'on décide à leur place c'est
ça qui nous ont dit dans les élections
c'est ce qu'ils ont dit à tout le monde
et il faut pas se tromper
maintenant sur le message des français
quand même fait pas un programme dans la
salle j'ai dit que j'ai dit oui la
différence de méthode
et puis après ce programme on va à
l'élaborer pierre par pierre
mais il faut refonder une perspective
pas simplement être dans les mesures
techniques pour votre livre vous parlez
beaucoup de la question de la
mondialisation vous dit que ça doit être
un peu le coeur de la réflexion et que
peut-être le ps a été un peu trop
optimiste sur elle n'a pas vu qu'il y
avait des perdants la mondialisation et
les gagnants celle-ci la fracture
sociale qui existe est au fond quelle
est la divergence
dans la gauche pas simplement en france
dans le monde entier quelle est la
divergence dans le courant progressiste
il ya ceux qui disent il faut s'adapter
à la mondialisation pour espérer la
maîtrise et il ya ceux qui disent on ne
peut pas maîtriser la mondialisation
faut résister mais on n'a pas trouvé le
moyen de ne pas être contre la
mondialisation puisque c'est un fait de
la maîtrise et par la résistance mais
c'est ça qui sur quoi il faut il faut il
faut travailler même que le dessin d'une
autre société d'une nouvelle société
d'une nouvelle france c'est ça qu'il
faut mettre en scène aujourd'hui
une dernière question peut-être vous
enfin vous allez étiez le premier
secrétaire jusqu'à la semaine dernière
donc actuellement il y en a pas mais on
sait qu'il va y avoir un congrès en
février
certains commençaient à avancé des pions
par exemple stéphane le foll dit qu'il
n'exclut pas d'être candidat ce que vous
pensez que c'est une bonne chose que ses
représentants de la hollande y entre
guillemets reprennent le flambeau du
parti socialiste ou est-ce qu'il faut
tourner la page
moi je suis vous savez vous connaissez
ça mieux que tout le monde pour une
direction collégiale restreinte
parce que je pense que dans le moment
présent personne personne ne peut
incarner à lui seul dans ses quelque
chose le parti social mais les
socialistes décideront ils trouveront
peut-être une personnalité je suis pour
une direction et direction collégiale y
compris après qu'on a oui oui oui mais
beaucoup plus resserré et 3,4 pas plus
et je pense que si nous distinguerait
d'ailleurs est ce qui distingue le parti
socialiste des deux c'est parti homme ou
femme marine le pen
wauquiez
macron mélenchon laon les socialistes
qu'on disait divisé travailleraient
ensemble et puis un moment donné
peut-être après les municipales trouver
la personnalité qui peut rassembler tout
le monde peut-être aller jusqu'à la
présidentielle en tant que responsable
ex responsable socialiste
est ce que vous avez vécu un moment
exhaltant mardi soir oui pour l'hommage
rendu à nicole bricq 1 puisqu'il ya eu
une réunion de deux cents personnes
c'est l'opinion qui révèle ce matin
cette soirée au cours de laquelle nous
dit on dsk a prononcé son premier
discours politique depuis la sphère du
sofitel à new york
alors vous y étiez oui c'était pas tout
à fait exact puisqu'il s'agissait de la
mort de nicole bricq oui mais le
discours fait par dsk par était là en
flammes et l'assistant usagers auront
rien il a fait un très beau discours
d'abord très amicale vis-à-vis de nicole
bricq il connaissait bien même s'il
avait des divergences il a essayé de
d'indiquer le point commun entre
commencé sa vie politique avec jean
pierre chevènement pour la terminer avec
terminé bon à valoir
malheureusement avec emmanuel macron
cette envie de faire bouger les lignes
et de bousculer hier la hisser fillon
est aujourd'hui le parti socialiste il a
indiqué qu' on pouvait travailler la
gauche et la droite ensemble mais qu'il
ne fallait pas les confond qui avait des
valeurs de droite et les valeurs de
gauche donc ça c'est un avertissement au
président de la république
on sent réparer comme ça vous rend reçu
comme ça voilà mais le président de la
république a fait aussi un beau discours
le françois hollande aussi pierre
moscovici aussi falloir une soirée de
recueillement
bon d'accord mais certains ont estimé
que dans sa posture dominique strauss
kahn en s'adressant à monsieur le
président de la république monsieur le
président semblait leur dire j'aurais à
votre place
mieux fait que vous ou je ferai mieux
que vous est-ce que c'est toute chose
que vous avez vous perçu vous le
connaissez bien
je le connais bien
alors dans ces cas-là il dit les choses
oui il n'est pas dans l'explicité donc
pas dans l'implicite dans je crois que
il avait envie d'indiquer ce qui était
un parcours qu'il a respecté il l'a fait
il s'est adressé à bien sûr à
l'assistance
mais au président de la république en
poste aujourd'hui et à l'ancien
président il a fait naître des regrets
bah oui tout le monde a trouvé qu'il a
été extrêmement qu'il était
brillantissime
enfin moi ça me ça me parle tant qu'ils
étaient brillantissime que c'était voilà
il y avait quatre citations assez longue
de mémoire
voilà donc bon bah c'est le personnage
il est comme ça fanny françois hollande
était présent vous l'avez dit on a
l'impression qu'il n'a pas dit son
dernier mot et qu'il veut toujours être
un acteur engagé dans la vie politique
est ce que vous pensez que son retour en
2022 est possible en tous les cas il est
ouvert comme toujours on sait jamais si
jamais voilà écoutez est ce qu'on
pensait que son ce que le secrétaire
général adjoint de l'elysée allait
devenir
trois ans plus tard président de la
république personne non bon tout est
ouvert voilà ils sont ouverts de
françois hollande il va encore être
question de la troisième partie des
proches de vérité merci stéphanie c'est
michael aimait ce que nous accueillons
maintenant
[Musique]
bonsoir michaëlle jean michel bonsoir
monsieur cambadélis je reprends le titre
de votre livre chronique d'une des bacs
2012-2017 pourquoi françois hollande at
il échoué pour des raisons objectives et
des raisons subjectives comme on disait
dans l'ancien temps dans l'ancien monde
des niveaux bien sûr dans des raisons
objectives qui sont à la fois la crise
du progressiste dans le monde entier
regarde ce qui se passe ce qui s'est
passé aux états unis ce qui se passe en
italie ce qui se passe en espagne ce qui
s'est passé en allemagne
et si tu sais bien sûr passer en france
mais dans d'autres pays c'est exactement
la même chose
j'en ai parlé tout à l'heure raison
objective parce que il a pris le gant au
moment où david strauss kahn n'a pas pu
se présenter raison objective parce que
il y avait des déficits importants
laissé par la droite et des raisons
subjectives qui ont été à la fois une
manière de faire en laissant toujours
tout ouvert jusqu'au dernier moment
en abordant les problèmes les uns après
les autres en donnant pas le sens de ce
qu'ils voulaient faire de sens on vous
avait résumé un peu votre propos disant
refus d'agir paraissent de penser c'est
bien j'ai parlé des 16e jeux par des
phases de jeu pas de françois hollande
de ce nom ce passage non parce que les
socialistes se sont installés je parle
pas du président la met des plus amers
globale dans un confort d'ailleurs ce
confort a conduit nombre d'entre eux à
suivre
emmanuel macron pouvoir être à nouveau
dans le confort dans un confort qui fait
que hier dans le bipartisme vous pouviez
vous pouvez un moment donné père mais
vous étiez sur le coup d'après de
l'emporter aujourd'hui c'est le
multipartisme et vous n'êtes plus dans
le lit partie ce confort parce que
certains pendant cinq ans sont passés
d'un ministère à l'autre tranquillement
confort parce que dira je pense à
personne de monsieur donne les
indications jordana c'est dans le livre
pour moi y'a vraiment devenir ministre
non plus donc j'ai eu beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup
non je dis pas ça mais bon confort parce
que certains sont passés de l'assemblée
nationale au sénat de l'ue sénat
l'assemblée nationale
bref
voilà et chacun avait son rond de
serviette dans les médias c'était
tellement simple tellement facile il y
avait ceux qui défendent et le
gouvernement et ceux qui le critiquaient
ça faisait le bonheur de vos chroniques
drame effet les amis frondeur il
suffisait de venir sur un plateau et
dire une bonne méchanceté bien vacharde
on était sûr d'être repris c'était
rigolo
bon ben voilà les socialistes ont vécu
dans ce moment là et à partir de là ils
n'ont pas pensé aux français on va
continuer sur françois hollande
oui en revivant peut-être belles
annonces du 1er décembre parce que là
elle vous a placé dans une situation
étonnante vous allez pouvoir dire à qui
vous avez pensé à ce moment là en
écoutant françois hollande et son fameux
renoncement d'exercice du pouvoir les
lieux du pouvoir et les rites du pouvoir
ne l'ont jamais fait perdre ma lucidité
ni sur moi même ni sur la situation car
je dois agir et aujourd'hui je suis
conscient des risques que ferait courir
une démarche la mienne qui ne
rassemblerait pas l'âge largement autour
d'elle aussi j'ai décidé de ne pas être
candidat à l'élection présidentielle
alors là vous pensez à je pensais rien
parce que je n'ai pas vu pas j'étais
dans l'avion pendant ce temps là oui
j'étais dans l'avion j'allais à prague
d'accord parfois quand tu prends que
vous avez vous avez pensé j'ai pensé que
c'était foutu
elle vous avez pensé surtout à benoît 16
oui j'ai pensé à benoît 16 parce qu'ils
renoncent et bientôt aussi je ne fais
pas parce que comme je venais de lire
lille à gand bel sur benoît cesse me
fait penser à vos renoncement avec tout
ce que cela voulait dire parce que
aujourd'hui on se gausse
mais c'est assez courageux quand même de
d'affronter les français de parler de
dire bah je renonce parce que les
conditions ne sont pas réunies
c'est quand même vous vous infligez vous
avoue même liste un certain point de vue
une défaite mais ce qui est important de
dire aussi c'est l'âme vous sentez que
c'est terminé c'est foutu
je la leur c'est là que je commence le
livre parce que tant que françois
hollande était candidat
on
beaucoup de désaccords entre nous
beaucoup de mes amis est très proche ne
pensait pas ce que je vais vous dire la
primaire avait comme but de désigner le
candidat qui peut gagner la
présidentielle surtout qu'ils pouvaient
battre marine à partir du moment où il
n'est plus là où il renonce il donne une
indication que ce n'est pas gagnable
pour les socialistes
donc ceux qui vont venir derrière
doivent se départager sur l'orientation
de la gauche et non plus sur doc sur
l'appréciation autant bien au moment où
il décide de ne pas se prononcer deux
candidats à l'élection présidentielle
ils repèrent le ps il en a peut-être pas
conscience mais c'est ce qui se passe
qu'est ce qui se passait dans les
caisses qui s'est passé dans l'esprit
des français avec un peu le fossoyeur du
parquet ce qui s'est passé a souvent là
les français se sont dits et socialistes
pensent qu'ils ne vont pas gagner la
présidentielle
donc il ya ceux qui ce sont des bassines
gagne pas la présidentielle il avait
déjà commencé à faire mouvement vers
juppé si je ne gagne pas la
présidentielle faut en trouver un qui
puisse battre marine le pen comme on n'a
pas envie ça soit fillon ben c'est macro
et macro ont commencé à monter et ceux
qui critiquaient la politique
gouvernementale se sont dits bourahli
socialistes ne vont pas être candidat au
deuxième tour de la présidentielle où
ils seront pas là donc autant crier avec
jean luc mélenchon
voilà donc à partir de là le parti
socialiste a commencé à être mangé
debout
est ce qu'on peut dire oui ou non
est ce qu'on peut dire que le parti
socialiste ne se porte pas mieux quand
il est dans l'opposition et se régénère
et dans l'opposition
oui se porte mieux il se portait mieux
on va voir c'est intéressant les cinq
ans ce qu'il se portait mieux parce
qu'on était dans le bipartisme et
c'était donc facile on avait la droite
donc que les gens allaient vers la
gauche
aujourd'hui l'offre politique est
multiple il y a un un fractionnement
considérable donc est ce que le parti
socialiste dans cette situation qui est
beaucoup plus délicate va tirer son
épingle du jeu et se rassurer à nouveau
le parti de l'alternative moi je le
pense mais encore faut-il de réaliser en
même temps je pense que contre un faux
contrairement aux sondages ne seront sur
le ring dans cinq ans pour la prochaine
élection présidentielle
oui oui et tout est oui parce que parce
que vous ne mettez pas la barre à
l'élection municipale dans là bas mais
c'est un chemin c'est donc
bien réussir les élections municipales
si on perd les élections municipales
évidemment la présidentielle est plus
compliqué mais vous savez je termine là
dessus macro notion rendra plus il aura
gouverné donc vous n'aurez pas le même
macron et mélenchon qui pendant trois
ans ou quatre ans aura divisé
ça ne sera plus le même donc vous aurez
une situation politique totalement
différente même si les uns réussissent
ici ou là tout sera ouvert c'est ce que
vous me dites voilà ah ben je continue
sur votre livre si vous permettez page
49 notamment de votre livre vous dites à
propos de ce quinquennat quelque part
que françois hollande n'a pas vu ce
ras-le-bol fiscale qui avait été
dénoncée par votre ami pierre moscovici
à l'époque nouveau site est d'ailleurs
pierre moscovici
pourquoi est ce que ne l'a pas vu venir
malgré les alertes et parce qu'il était
pleinement et totalement dans la
réduction des déficits qui nous avait
laissé nicolas sarkozy est ce que c'est
ça qui a choqué les français n'ont pas
cessé dans l'europe du quinquennat ce
que je dis dans le livre c'est que ça
coagulé la droite parce que la droite
elle ne voulait plus de sarkozy elle a
choisi le l'antisarkozysme le plus
praticable mais dès le lendemain elle
était contre le projet
la politique de la gauche bon et quand
vous augmentez les impôts et qui en même
temps vous faites le mariage pour tous
vous qu une sérieusement la droite et on
n'a jamais vu on n'a jamais vu sous la
vème république un président françois
mitterrand ou des premiers ministres
lionel jospin avoir si peu de soutiens à
droite parce que d'emblée les choses
près par ailleurs il fallait le faire
fallait redresser la france sur le plan
budgétaire et c'est très belle loi qui
est le mariage porteuse il fallait
l'assumer mais où vous constatons ce que
ça a produit qu'est ce qui symbolise
pour vous le plus le raté de ce
quinquennat est ce que ces questions à
choix multiples la sphère leonarda
l'épisode de la rue du cirque casque
avec le scooter la déchéance de
nationalité la loi travail déchéance de
nationalité en matière c'est donc il ya
des chances de nationalité aloi travail
pourquoi parce que nous terminons
l'année 2015 avec des élections
régionales plutôt réussi pour le parti
socialiste même si nous avons perdu nous
avons quand même cinq régions nous avons
la coop 21 une situation économique qui
s'en est rose en a besoin d'un billy
commence à produire ses effets et la
droite qui se disent à tel point que les
sondages décembre/janvier draineront et
ça sera la dernière fois
françois hollande devant nicolas sarkozy
mais tout le monde pense que ça et je
n'ai pas l'impression aussi que
l'affairé godard d'aller faire du casque
de scooter ça quand même cassé l'image
du président c'est ce que vous verrez
que vous étiez vous me demandez un
tiercé donc rivés sur dix étaient tous a
été cédée français rim et tout ça a été
surmontée puisque nous faisons 24% aux
élections départementales et aux
élections régionales donc cela
démontrait que les français avaient
décidé de mettre ça derrière leurs
épaules
donc on était dans un nouveau cycle on a
cassé ceci alors vous écrivez quand même
un point important c'est que pour vous
les chèques du quinquennat était inscrit
dès le départ c'est là qu'il faut
peut-être cité le rôle d'arnaud
montebourg
oui parce que arnaud montebourg qui
était avec dominique strauss kahn
laurent fabius et quelques autres un des
rénovateurs du mans qui socialisent
derrière martine aubry avait
on avait fait un pacte qui n'est pas le
pacte de marrakech dont appel à l'époque
qui était tout simplement non c'était le
pacte de la gare de lyon puisque c'est
cet effet la gare de lyon voilà encore
un scoop et qui était très simple où on
va disjoindre la présidentielle de la
refondation du parti socialiste et on se
mettra derrière celui qui aura le plus
de chances de l'emporter
or au deuxième tour de la primaire
arnaud montebourg choisi celui qui est
le plus éloigné de lui puisqu'ils
défendent et la démondialisation est pas
martine aubry c'est son choix
rien à dire là-dessus mais le germe de
la division et au delà à partir de là
mais je crois que tout le monde va le
comprendre petit à petit à partir de là
ce deuxième tour de la primaire à
encoder où c'est le code génétique du
quinquennat parce que vous aviez
d'emblée à la fois l'orientation
soutenue portée par françois hollande
qui était tendanciellement sous les 3%
et son contraire d'abord est pas marché
qu'est ce que vous voyez comme à venir
pour françois hollande aujourd'hui
encore une fois je vous dirais comme le
tout est ouvert
en tous les cas il veut être un
attaquant est tout à fait en politique
varna vu cette image quand même qui a
marqué les gens de ce renoncement
une fois qu'on renonce on peut revenir
sur vous comme ça dans le moment présent
je vais vous dire non ce sera difficile
bon là où il est dans la situation à dia
il nous reçoit dans quelle situation en
trois ans vous le savez départ fait
ont-ils encore une envie de froome et
rolande d'aller français ont peut-être
envie dessus pas de stabilité et c'est
peut-être dit on chez les socialistes
qui seraient imposées d'ici là par
exemple que c'est vous qui espérait
peut-être nous est posé question vous
parler également de manuel valls ne pas
tendre avec lui et lui il rêve d'un
come-back aussi
j'ajoute aussi alors qu'en pensez vous
des gens qui rêvent d comme dans son
coeur le dit c'est du désert ou d'état
mr en politique
moi je manuel valls est un ami et
j'étais complètement éberlué que cet
homme si droit s'y intègre qui a fait de
cela la marque duval cisme ce soit
vassaliser il s'est perdu
il est perdu mais il est perdu et vous
vous avez tout à le répéter qu'il y aura
un socialiste sur le ring je serai
toujours sur le ring vous y avait pour
nom moi je suis j'ai dit je serais un
spectateur désengager puisque je ne suis
plus la tête du parti socialiste je vais
être un apporteur d'idées je vais une
voix de la gauche
moi je ferai ça pendant pendant quatre
ans ou cinq ans paris les conditions de
d'un candidat gagnant des élections
présidentielles vrai ce que vous dites
que vous y avez pensé ne serait ce que
quelques secondes dans votre chambre
d'hôtel
oui on c'était parce que voilà il faut
donner ses pensées ses arrière pensées
j'ai explosé de rire tout de suite je
rassure les téléspectateurs voient bien
que c'est pour quand le deuxième livre
qu'on sache il est en préparation
je sais pas l'année prochaine et ça sera
aussi un livre politique
ce sera un livre politique mais là sur
la perspective théorique de ce qu'est la
gauche pour se fera à mon avis moins
médiatisés on verra ne mésestimez pas
notre intérêt pour les problèmes de fond
à tous les cas celui-ci sort aux
éditions de l'archipel et la semaine
prochaine c'est bruno retailleau
sénateur hier que vous connaissez qui
sera notre invité dans cette émission
bonsoir bonsoir monsieur cambadélis
bonsoir
[Musique]